right from the beginning the mission
statement of deep mind accorded a large
role to neuroscience we see neuroscience
as a useful guide in our search for
solutions to to AI and also as providing
methods for us to validate the ideas
that we're coming up with in our AI
research the brain is arguably still the
only example that we have of something
that approximates the kind of
intelligence we're trying to build and
so it seems like a good idea to pay some
attention to how it works at D mind the
way neuroscience informs AI research I
think it works at several different
levels so there are cases where we're
interested in very specific findings
from neuroscience research like memory
replay for example or the way that
dopamine works in the brain another tool
that we use every day at deep mind which
is something called reinforcement
learning which is about how you can
learn to behave effectively given only
rewards and punishments that also came
originally out of studies of animal
learning and psychology we look for
opportunities to take what we've learned
about those very specific aspects of
neural function and then translate them
into things that will work for AI in my
experience so far I've I've realized
that there's a subtler and maybe more
important way in which neuroscience
informs AI research which is that when
you have neuro scientists in the
building
interacting with engineers and computer
scientists and experts in machine
learning you get a wide variety of
intuitions and viewpoints and
associations which ends up paying off
for AI research the way I think about it
is back in the days when people were
trying to build machines that could fly
they might have discovered the solution
without worrying about how birds are
able to fly and in the end the solution
for machines ended up looking different
from the solution that birds use but at
the same time it seems like it would
have been silly for people trying to
solve
flight to completely ignore Birds and
that's I think what we would be doing in
AI research if
we didn't attend to neuroscience it's
it's there for us to learn from it seems
it seems inevitable that it can provide
guidance in our search for solutions
they are and if we can do those two
things in the same building with the
same researchers working on it I think
we stand a better chance of succeeding
[Music]